Jacinda is in New York I just send a
welcome to the Dave Ramsey show thank
you guys you guys are so awesome because
of you I just finished paying off my
credit card bills and I'm ready to take
on my student loans Oh way to go yes
way to go here oh yes how much student
loans you have Jacinda um I have 16,000
and yeah so but I'm on that now and it's
just awesome to see how this all works
so I'm calling it because my I'm calling
as a concerned daughter I love my dad
still I just graduated out of college
and my family was struggling before the
pandemic and because of it now you know
his small business is completely shut
down but I don't see this as a wake-up
call that he needed you know he hasn't
even tried to get a job like temporarily
and I don't I it's really sad to see and
I don't know what I can get him on your
guys's teaching you know it's hard he's
very stubborn you know I I'm trying to
say the right things because you know I
have an interesting great father one of
my father's and and I just want to say I
can understand how you feeling
I'll let Dave speak from the father
perspective but I want to speak directly
to you don't allow this situation to
over stress you and what you need to be
doing for your life be a concern
daughter but don't let your concern for
your father
now jeopardize and impact your personal
life because your father has some in his
decisions speak life into them give them
some suggestions but make sure that
you're getting through this season make
sure that you're healthy during this
season but as far as in from the father
perspective Dave I there's not too much
I can really speak into that cuz I'm not
a father
well I don't know that you have to be I
mean it's bottom line is just that's a
child to parent with both of you being
adults
is is difficult to give advice yeah
we call it the powder but syndrome once
somebody's powdered your but they don't
really want your opinion on money or sex
so you know and so you know he just you
know all I think the best thing you can
do is talk about your story alive hey
Dad I just paid off these credit cards
hey Dad I'm working on this student loan
debt hey Dad I'm so excited about this
stuff I'm learning this stuff from Dave
Ramsey man if you read this book from
Anthony O'Neill you read this book from
Dave Ramsey dad hey here's some ideas
dad here's what I'm doing dad not waving
your finger at him and wagging your
finger and saying dad you're stupid
that'll never work
with very few fathers anyway a few of
them are wimpy enough to allow their
kids to do that to him that's true and
so you you know you just got it if you
talk about your story though he'll be
proud of you and he might catch on yeah